I gotta figure out a way
three years worth of food here on a
planet where nothing grows luckily I'm a
botanist Ridley Scott's 2015 hit movie
the Martian grows two hundred and twenty
eight million dollars and gave NASA a
real-life publicity boost the movie was
based on the best-selling book by
first-time author Andy weir
now we're is out with his second novel
called Artemis and it is already a
best-seller it's a murder mystery that
takes place on the moon Jeff Glor sat
down with we're at the intrepid air Snee
Air and Space Museum here in New York I
always wanted to be a writer but I also
like eating regular meals so when I went
to college I went with software
engineering and writing ultimately was
my hobby and I kind of bungled into
success of the Martian so now I get to
now I get to be a writer with no
publisher backing him Andy weir
self-published the Martian in 2012 it
was discovered by readers everywhere
pulled into Weir's unmistakable blend of
real-world science and otherworldly
drama the Martian has since sold more
than 5 million copies and led to one
very successful movie I have no way to
contact NASA and even if I could it's
gonna be four years until a manned
mission can reach me you have a loyal
following and I know you hear a lot from
the folks who read your stuff you
respond to every single email and notes
yep every email they took the time to
email me it's it seems only reasonable
to respond if they have questions I'll
answer the questions if they just said
hey I love your book I'm like thanks
it's probably supposed to be Mars but it
looks more like Venus
your tie gets an S so what's it what's
your name a number of weird fans came to
an Artemis book signing in the Space
Shuttle Pavilion at the intrepid if you
actually do end up being the first
person on Mars this will be worth so
much money
eager to hear more about a lunar crime
novel set in the late 21st century about
a woman named Jasmine Bashara who tries
to pull off a huge heist
tell me about jazz jazz was born in
Saudi Arabia but when she was six years
old she and her father moved to Artemis
which is the only city on the moon she
grew up in sort of a low-income
blue-collar household as an adult which
is when the story takes place she's a
porter which basically means a delivery
person but she makes most of her money
off of illegal smuggling everyone seems
to forget this but I'm a smuggler not a
saboteur not an action hero not a city
planner a smuggler actress rosario
Dawson narrates Artemis for audible in
the beginning I had competition but not
anymore what else was it that attracted
you to to setting this on the moon the
moon has an enormous amount of this
mineral called anorthite and if you
smelt an earth if you refine it what you
get out of it is aluminium silicon
calcium and oxygen it gives you
aluminium to build your moon base and
oxygen to fill it with it's amazing it's
like it's asking to be colonized
and this is fascinating for all of us I
think when we're gonna make these lunar
trips regularly if you can drive the
price of booster technology if you can
drive that price down to the point that
middle-class people can afford to go
into space then you will have a space
boom a proper huge explosion in the
space industry like the airline boom in
the 40s and 50s would you go to the moon
if you no you wouldn't no no no I write
about very people I'm not one of them I
am an earthbound misfit I'll stay right
here Thanks I'm afraid of flying
so really yeah really yeah I'm here in
New York and I live in California I have
to take meds and stuff just to fly out
here I have a general problem with
anxiety and have for most of my life and
I spent most of my life just thinking
well I'm broken and there's nothing I
can do about that now there are meds for
that I take medication and therapy and
stuff people know there's a lot of stuff
for depression but they don't know that
there's a lot of stuff for anxiety
so to anybody who hears this or has
anxiety problems I heard you go talk to
a doctor your anxiety is not just a
failure of your personality it's a
physical problem that can be solved with
medical solutions so how does that how
does that manifest itself in your
characters when you're writing a story
if you're thinking of everything that
can go wrong that helps you write the
story
[Music]
especially when you're writing stories
about everything going wrong there
nothing does for your character yeah my
character he's kind of have a rough time
sometimes this is the enterprise it
never had a crew was used for
aerodynamic testing fans may be able to
visit the city of Artemis in theaters
soon Fox optioned the rights to the book
even before was released so what's next
for you I would love for Artemis to be
my own personal playground where I can
have lots and lots of different stories
with different main characters because
it's a city you don't want to go to
distant galaxies or stars I may I may
well do that in the immediate future
I've got ideas for a sequel for Artemis
but I've got book ideas enough to last
me the rest of my life just sign yeah
okay
it's just you know what am I most
excited by at any moment and what do I
think the readers want to read for CBS
this morning Saturday Jeff Glor New York
I think that's the first time he's
really talked about his anxieties
fascinate and how he uses that actually
to make better books that are soon to be
I can't imagine Artemis isn't gonna be
made into a film he sure travels a lot
in his imagination you guys